[Music]
what is that something that would
distinguish us as designers in Singapore
do we have a higher purpose and if so
what is that higher purpose for us in
Singapore here and that is why I asked
this question what are the biggest
challenges of Singapore and I want to
see how this community in front of me
can help navigate these challenges or
help overcome these challenges in
Singapore's economic challenges going
forward
one of the biggest constraint is no
longer land manpower finances it is
interestingly carbon energy usage and
covered so I'm going to challenge the
design community here what can you do
how do we overcome the carbon challenge
and build a new economy how do we
overcome the challenges of urban living
faceless urban living to build real
communities for ourselves regardless of
race language religion regardless of
economic and social background that we
will all grow up and grow home together
what can designers help us to do from
the macro City planning to the micro
material use and everything else in
between so there's just one example of
how designers are important to solve the
big challenges or what I call the grand
challenges of Singapore that will
distinguish us I have Grand Challenges I
need your help I need your help because
you are the people who are thinking
about such things and help us get it
right every successful society as they
become more mature there's a risk a
tendency to become more ossified a lot
of people like to design for privacy now
privacy today is social isolation
tomorrow when people grow up how do we
marry design for privacy with social
inclusion and that is the challenge in
Singapore we have 80% public housing but
how are we going to design our public
housing such that it just doesn't
provide a house with four walls but a
living space and a space where
communities born and come together your
job is not just this
you are Moreland you are almost
designing how we develop as a society
how we grow as a people the kind of
value systems that we have it starts
from the very small thing people ask me
why is it I Singaporeans do now to
return their trees when you go to Hawker
centers so why is it a Singaporeans
don't pick up the rubbish order as a
role for the designers too much much too
much people who get into the correct
behavior so that individually and
collectively we become a better people a
better society and a stronger nation
I would like to pride myself that my
designers in Singapore has that higher
purpose to solve the Grand Challenges of
our country which in turn if successful
can be scaled to the rest of the world
[Music]